hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar extracellular vesicles as
diagnostic and therapeutic tools for
cancer
I am Alexis Krause of laberd's and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lappers and brought to you
by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license
click on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box located on the far
left your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits I now present today's
speaker Sara bliss Auto
PhD student and Technology for health
Sara is a PhD student in professor
Birch's colloidal clinical chemistry
laboratory at the University of Russia
in Italy currently she's also a visiting
pre-doctoral student in professor
Wolfram
nano medicine and extracellular vesicles
group at Mayo Clinic in Florida in 2015
sara graduated from the University of
Russia and Italy with a master's degree
in medical biotechnology
her research focuses on exploring the
targeting and drug delivery capacity of
extracellular vesicles in vitro and in
vivo for a complete biography owner
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen Sara
you may now begin your presentation
hello everyone my name is Sarah visit
Joe and today I'm going to talk to you
about extracellular vesicles and they
for seen applications as therapeutic
tools for cancer the data that I'm going
to discuss while playing during my
teaching project so the experiments were
performed both at the University of
Russia in Italy and at Mayo Clinic in
Jacksonville Florida United States let's
start with the brief outline of my
presentation I will start introducing
after solar vegetables then I will move
to technology for use or extracellular
vesicle isolation and characterization
then I will talk about a robust method
to determine those dependent objectives
of extracellular vesicles by culture
cells then I will talk about
extracellular vesicles vesicles as
source of new liver cancer biomarkers
and as the extracellular vesicles as
supporting lipid bilayer
excessive our vesicles are amateur
genius class of celsa to develop
articles then we can distinguish between
microvesicles also called extra zones
budget from the plasma membrane that has
a size ranging from 100 to 1000
nanometers and extra zone or than the
thermal origin with the size ranging
from 30 to 150 nanometers exothermic
vesicles are delimited by a lipid
bilayer derived from cellular membrane
and in case by active cargoes mainly
small genetic materials and peptide
throughout the presentation I will also
refer to them with their acronym CDs etc
vesicle transport and protect molecular
information so and they transfer this
information to target cells so they are
also able to modify the target cell
metabolism and phenotype transferring
their bioactive cargo except on our
vegetables mediate interstellar
communication and support both
physiological and pathological processes
for example accordingly to a growing
number of studies excess my vesicles
have the capability to initiate the
primitive static link formation and also
to promote the absolute critical
accessibly ization in the past years due
to the central role that they play in
the cell communication extrasolar
vesicles funny to be envisioned as a
valuable sensory strategy for various
biomedical application for example we
can use extra solar vesicles in
Diagnostics as source of new biomarkers
or as a material to build by a sensor or
also we can use Excel a verticals in
therapeutics for example stem cells
derived excess or large vesicles can be
used in regenerative medicine or excess
or our vegetables can be also used
as drug delivery vehicles or again they
can represent the target of therapy
exothermic vesicles can be isolated from
many different biological fluids the
biological foods are complex biological
matrices composed by a plethora of other
nanofied bias material that can overlap
in size and density XSL are vesicles
before we need to be really careful
doing the extracellular vesicle
isolation in order to not concentrate
together with our disease other
nanoscale molecules and objects that may
act as contaminants in the final
formulation of course contaminant can
change the overall physical chemical
properties of the simulation and may
affect the final biological sample
activity in fact contaminants can exert
a biological function in concomitant
with
XSL our vesicles emphasizing or hiding
accelerates both function and causing
also artifacts and with leading results
the simple matrix that we can use to own
separate access along vesicles is the
cell culture medium that is considered
simple since we can control its
composition but we can also process more
complex biological foods such as
patient-derived samples that require
much more attention in order to separate
the silver vesicles we can apply
different protocol or isolation strategy
according both to the sample volumes but
also to the sample application the
widely used methods to process large
volume of sample is for example
ultracentrifugation but if we need to
process a smaller volume of sample we
can also use commercially available i
relationship based on polymer
precipitation and for example of the
gradient made of sucrose or unix alone
or also
sighs exclusion chromatography the
choice of the proper isolation is method
is not trivial as shown by this
following data in this work we isolated
extracellular vesicles starting from the
same volume of the same sample mainly
one ml of serum foundation affected by
multiple myeloma XSL a vesicle were
isolating using different techniques
cellulose insulation and
ultracentrifugation namath as EMC
polymer base precipitation kit named as
kit
sucrose an additional gradient name as
SG and I change respectively as you can
see after the isolation samples were
analyzed by Western with analogous to
visualize typical IV markers
interestingly all the samples show
characteristically biomarkers
corroborating the presence of
theoretically comparable and
consistently population of in over four
different and evie samples but if we
further evaluate the samples checking
for example their microstructure through
atomic force microscopy we can see that
the sample I relate to through
ultracentrifugation and/or with the
precipitation chips display effect
metrics that surround our XSL are
vesicles in contrast the preferential
from your external and sucrose gradient
do not present any trace of losses or
matches
so we analyze also if the peppered
Imaginex present inside the preparation
influence the preparation final
biological activity we specifically
analyzed the nf-kb nuclear translocation
induced in endothelial cells after the
exposure to XSL were vesicles I believed
upon generalization affected by multiple
myeloma
cells were incubated with the
preparation I related through you see
any precipitation kit and as you can see
they didn't know did not show a
significant and skb nuclear signal
in contrast the cells incubated with the
pure every preparation obtained from
your external and sucrose radiance sure
showed a strong and skd nuclear
translocation signal the overall results
demonstrated that the choice of the
exosome isolation method from biological
huge piece of capital importance and
that also the sample purity grade should
be checked before doing further
experiments with our extracellular
vesicles other than the previously cited
isolation methods there are other there
are also other technique that are now
used to concentrate extracellular
vesicles from biological foods for
example tangential flow filtration is a
science-based technique use the
concentrate extracellular vesicles TFS
couples permeable membrane filtration
and tangential flow to obtain efficient
concentration of a chiseler vesicle from
poloidal MAGIX tangential filtration is
different from conventional dedenne
filtration because the fluid flows
tangentially actual across the surface
so the flow avoids the filter cake
formation in this study to evaluate CFS
performances we compared the TFS with
the youth ultracentrifugation
side-by-side for processing large volume
of cell culture media we processed by
the two methods of the centrifugation
and contentious of hydration have
comparable by you
properties for example their site
distribution is the same and ranges
between 60 and 600 nanometers the
transmission electron microscopy showed
with both methods nano sized particles
with the fara code with a spherical
structure characteristic to that of
extracellular vesicles and both the
sample analyzed with Western blot showed
characteristic XSL or vesicle marker
such as CD 63 and CD 81 whereas the next
sense under plastic and endoplasmic
reticulum marker used as a control to
detect intracellular vesicle
contaminants was undetectable and this
corroborates the sample purity which is
enriched just in excessive vesicles so
compared to ultracentrifugation
tangential flow filtration resulted in
one to two orders of magnitude increase
in SSL or vesicle recovery per million
culture cells and accordingly the yields
of extracellular Volturi
the field of accessory vesicles from the
same amount of media 100ml was improved
approximately 5 fold with conduction
through filtration furthermore the
ability of both method to separate
contaminants with typical protein size
was afraid by spiking the samples with
known amount of Tours and albumin the
results reveal that CFS leads to a 40
fold improvement in the ability to
remove albumin compared to Reuters
anticipation
furthermore the albumin concentration
differed substantially among the three
sample process by ultracentrifugation
highlighting our legs effective edge
consistency of its procedure so once we
are able to properly isolate and
characterize a formulation of
extracellular vesicle we still need to
determine our sample concentration in
fact the titration of our sample is
fundamental as demonstrated by this work
which proposes a robust method to occur
to determine those dependent a picture
of accessory vesicle spy cells this
method is based on consistent the
relative dosing of highly pure nanofiber
cellular vesicles and flow site
symmetric analysis specifically in this
work we isolated extracellular vesicles
from the serum of healthy blood donors
after the isolation we label the
vesicles with a green fluorescent
epiphytic probe and then we incubated
drawing dosing of vesicles with
different type of cancer cells both
human and mouse cancer cells after three
hours of information
cells were washed collected and analyzed
by flow cytometry the positive - flora
stem cells were the cells that perform
idiotic
interestingly the data indicated that
theorem exosome isolated from healthy
individuals are internalized by both
mouths and human cancer cells displaying
specific codependent profiles
furthermore different cell lines
displayed different uptake profiles
these differences may have federal
origins ascribable both to sell or
exosome phenotype in particular at the
intermediate those of 2.5% to the 12x
ozone h cell line showed a specific
signature of uptick ratio various of the
highest X's on those when saturating
condition arise the internalization is
involved a percentage of cells gradient
greater than 50% for all the cell lines
this specifically suggests that at the
highest X's on concentration the active
is mainly determined by and specific
mechanisms due to the sited saturating
conditions these soaring forces that the
restoration of that determination of
cell line specific codependent update
profile is the derailment starting point
to significally undertake more
sophisticated targeting the limb very
experiments it be those working ranges
of powerful analytical tool to set the
optimal solution for further
investigation and becomes a requirement
for the correct pick up and
interpretational of any individual and
in the vault so now that we were able to
properly isolate and characterize and
those our EXO cellular vegetable
formulations we can further study in the
extracellular vesicle composition for
example in this study we used RNA
sequencing to perform a first
comprehensive overview of the expression
profile of coding and non
according trance transcript carried by
XSL a vesicle secreted from four
representative human liver cancer cell
lines three of the liver cancer which
were we're happy to carcinoma and one
was hepatoblastoma cells the
characterization of the RNA cargo in
case in the extracellular vesicles
secreted by these for liver cancer cell
lines we bring to the identification of
new diagnostic markers useful as liver
cancer diagnostic or prognostic markers
we know indicate that liver cancer is
one of the major causes of the cancel of
cancer-related death and its early
diagnosis can significantly improve the
five years patient survival the results
highlighted a high eternal Jannetty
across the small XSL or vesicle RNA
content of the four cell line and
specifically if we look at the XSL a
vesicle micro RNA content we can see
that among the ten most abundant micro
rna's which counts at least 50 percent
of the extracellular vesicle micro RNA
cargo some micro Renee were consistently
present across all four every population
and specifically micro RNA 21:50 it was
the most expressed across all the
samples interestingly micro RNA 21 was
already found to be secreted through
extracellular vesicles and overexpressed
in serum and plasma sample of facial
affected by liver cancer this
corroborates hypothesis test that these
microRNAs can represent a good
circulating non-invasive diagnostic and
prognostic liver cancer biomarker hu h6
extracellular vesicle which are
hepatoblastoma accessory
basically carrying said the most septic
subset of microRNAs leasing or
increasing low concentration of micro
enemies which were particular email
abundant in the other
XSL of ethical samples and carrying a
unique subset of other micro names such
as the micro rna's 371 372 and 373
cluster this is a cluster that has been
already specifically linked to human
embryonic stem cells and is directly
associated to embryonic carcinoma
hepatoblastoma cell line at 1886 is
considered to be an embryonic tumor and
overexpress also jnana my foreign aid
373 and my grenade 371 so the high
abundance of these microRNAs cluster in
extracellular vesicle release from
hepatoblastoma cells
confirm the hypothesis that leaves
microwave which has had already been
proposed as a blood based biomarker for
more aggressive tumors may also be good
candidates as a pataga solo markers this
last example in said talk about another
application of the extracellular vesicle
specifically in this case we engineer
our Excel or vesicle synthesizing the
first supportive lipid bilayer made with
extracellular vesicles and I I will call
it with the acronym FV s LD b AV s OB
patterns in two dimensions the key
properties of extracellular vesicle
membrane which present
intermediate intermediate complexity
between synthetic mimics such as
liposome
and natural cell membranes and have the
innate link to sanitize and function of
the originating cells so for this reason
we investigating the formation pathway
and the properties of nature shall be
and we synthesize our a VSO game
starting from nano sized as just
extracellular vesicles purified from
trans into cells which are a prostatic
cancer nearing cell line used as a model
for prosthetic cancer
so extracellular vesicles were separated
for cell culture media of 22mm cells and
they were careful characterized trusty
to access Ella vesicles displayed all
the characteristics extrasolar vegetable
biomarkers and worsley from
intracellular nano sized contaminants
they were also round shape and nano
sized and we also investigated the
topography of some of X proteins inside
the extracellular vegetable structure
performing a dedicated dot blot sa creep
and without the resurgent the presence
of the detergent is fundamental because
it disrupts the AVA membrane and throat
both membrane and cargo proteins whereas
the essay performed without the
detergent delete a XSL vesicle impact
and that selectively probes the membrane
proteins with outside oriented attitudes
so this soft what results we can see
that two proteins an x + 5 and sis art
were exposed in the outer necklace of
our extracellular vesicle membrane where
as a go to is encased inside the actual
inside the XSL our vegetable structure
we further analyze the a VSO leave
during information in this incentive
ography imaging image we can see the
central part where the abs will be is
already formed and here on the side you
can still intense in structure
extracellular vesicles
we
we then also wanted to get a first hint
whether the BSOD also kicks in to
dimension the topology of the native
three dimension a demon brain and that
also further indication of on the Avs lb
structure so to do so we investigated
the accessibility in our AV assembly of
the proto-oncogene tyrosine protein
kinase as SRC sis art this protein is
involved in about fifty percent of
tumors and the play also a key role in
signaling and the psychosis and exercise
all those processes moreover research
and was found highly enriched in our
extracellular vesicle formulation and
its association and it was specifically
associated to the outermost left of our
accessory a vegetable membrane the Avs
lb and a controlled support a lipid
bilayer made with synthetic liposomes
made named as popc SLV where initially
both labeled with red shorts and
lipophilic probe and then where immuno
afaid with a green fluorescent labeled
antibody against uses art for the
control popc SLV the green fluorescent
signal of the second of the antibody is
completely absent this confirmed that no
one specific interaction between the
primary and the antibody and the support
emitted by layer is present contrary in
the vs LD this show section with the
test touched regions where the green
fluorescent signal is present and also
overlays with the red signal of the
lipophilic probe confirming the
colocalization of
red liquid probe and the green antibody
so this data indicate that the V HLV
displays touch regions that preserve the
original protein C Sark so we can say
that merging the overall result
we can we can say that we were able to
sympathize and to analyze the structure
of our extracellular vesicle made
supporting lipid bilayer and that they
are formed from some nano size of
cellular vesicles isolated from cell
culture media following a characteristic
crowding fusion pathways furthermore
this supporting lipid bilayer even after
their synthesis still preserve proteins
which are characteristic of the starting
accessory a vesicle population
conclusively why we did that we did an
excellent vesicle support a lipid
bilayer because we think that this could
be a tool for study the so far and
accessible properties of the
extracellular vesicle membrane and also
because they could advance extracellular
vesicle made sa but also biosensors and
also because they can represent a
novelty in biogenic surfaces and
interfaces via technology in conclusion
with this brief seminar I just wanted to
introduce what extracellular vegetables
are and give first hint on their
possible future application so taken
together we can say that cancer cell
derived the special are vesicles have
great potential for improving the
diagnosis and treatment of cancer of
tumor disease thank you so much for your
attention and now I am open to questions
thank you
Thank You Sara for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is we can
use different approaches in order to
separate V's from their matrix are they
always invasive towards sample
properties
so hello everyone yes as I said during
the presentation we can leave many kind
of different isolation approaches and
some of them are well known to affect
specifically these structure and
therefore also every properties such as
for example ultracentrifugation
sometimes if both authentification has a
poor yield also because during the
sample processing we damaged and so lost
a lot of our excessive levels so I would
prefer new generation isolation
techniques to isolate XSL our radicals
such as the tangential so filtration
that I cited in my presentation but
there are also many other approaches
also HPLC that works in control range of
stressors and so they are more delicate
and gentle with their with the
biological samples
now our next question Sarah can I know
TFS cutoff range for X ohm for exosomes
enrichments
yes sir so in this case we use a to cut
off because we did two filtration steps
in the first filtration step we use a
cut-off that eliminated all the
particles with the size above 600
nanometers and in the second step we
eliminated all the particles with the
size below 30 to 40 nanometers so we
kept the population that surely goes
between 50 nanometers and 600 nanometers
why do you why do you not analyze
exosomes directly instead of
interactions with them with the cells
and then analyze
well thank you for this question because
it's really clever so in two words
resolution issue because when we want to
visualize a particle a force and
particle with the size below 100
nanometers the resolution that we need
must be really high really powerful so
in this case we wanted to use instead
two methods such as quantification
methods and also detection so photometry
that are really commonly used in all the
the laboratories for that reason we
wanted to study the pure the positive to
fluoresce themselves that allowed us to
get a higher resolution instead of the
exosome because they are not physical in
classical flow cytometry
you
our cell cultures good evie sources for
the massive production or purification
of v's
actually I think that they are a good
a good starting point I mean they are a
simple biological system of course we
can we can move them to 2d organoid and
so on but let's talk about the societal
subculture is a good part in point
because it allows to get high volume of
biological foods from where we can get
our XSL our vesicles and also there are
new words now that are that are using
specifically much complicated system
such as continued by a reactor based
cultures that can even more get closer
to what our real convention of
extracellular vesicle secretion so I
think that they are a good starting
point as I said
ladies and gentlemen we are getting so
many good questions in today so please
keep them coming in as a reminder any
questions we don't have time for today
we'll be answered by the speaker via the
contact of information that you provided
at the time of the registration let's
keep going with them did you investigate
differing culture conditions for example
cell confluence media compositions
supplementation 2d vs. 3d cultures on
evey production or cargo content
this is a really interesting question so
yes we investigated with the
productivity of the cells in different
conditions and how it varied the excess
over vesicle secretion and I can say
that cells fitted cells that are 100%
confluent do not produce a lot of
vesicles as if they are let's say 60 to
80 percent confluence because so in that
case they need to communicate between
each other so they secrete the vesicles
other than that I know that starvation
of the cells may vary the extracellular
vesicle composition because we
introduced a stressor and also the
percentage of of oxygen and that we used
during the the cell culturing yes this
are meaningful variable of our
experiment
I never investigated instead 2 D and 3
the difference between 2d and 3d
cultures but this is a really
interesting point thank you
our next question is a two-part question
could you please talk a little excuse me
could you please talk a little about
imaging of extracellular vesicles and
what is considered state-of-the-art for
imaging of isolated vesicles
I'm sorry I had a really bad servicing
community please them the question of
course it's just so you can see it's
question number 12 and it's a two-part
question could you please stop talking
about the imaging of extracellular
vesicles and what is considered
state-of-the-art for imaging of isolated
vesicles so I've said before very that
they are nanofied so they are going to
be tricky to Mitch in my laboratory
experience
I used mainly AFM atomic force
microscopy and also TEM so electron
microscopy and specifically cryo TEM
work really really well and they have
they are both make with the resolution
that is okay to in extracellular
vegetables you can also use two photons
microscope and also compose microscope
do that they are good too and the other
part
the isolation technique right
I am yes
considered state-of-the-art for imaging
of isolated vesicles
I'm sorry III really I really had better
service the question number 13 you said
12 number 12 12 though I
okay what is my super state-of-the-art
for imaging okay
again AFM and electron microscopy both
TM and priority KMA mainly yes I would
say that
so there are next questions is there any
difference yet between the exosome
isolation technique used with adherent
cells compared with suspension cells
poor to my knowledge I would say no the
only thing that you wanted to wish that
you want to be sure is that you
eliminate all the sell and sell Bay
Breeze but either if you use a
differential centrifugation step or if
you use size base isolation methods and
so on all these isolation approaches
allows you to discard first cells dead
cells and cell debris and then proceed
to excess over vegetable isolation so no
there are no difference to my knowledge
at least
so our next question is again a two-part
question
do you find that your cell culture
process affects easy yield and the next
part is does your cell culture
preparation need special media
supplements or any other form of
optimization to grow cells that will
give you a high yield of edie's
and said before yes something is really
some parameter during cell culture are
really important to to have also a good
yield during your harvesting for example
the cell confluence and the cell the
cell media may vary accordingly to the
culture cells of course another
suggestion that I have is to use the
special commercially available SPS
settle bovine serum as a supplement or
that is specifically depleted of
endogenous
XSL large vesicles so you won't have
them as contaminant of your preparation
because of course they won't exert their
own biological activity and you don't
want that and these two are the main
comments
now cell culture conditions partially
mimic the body condition but do not
reproduce the same environment do
cultured cells produce the same vesicles
as the cells in their native environment
as a maggot tissue or organ
unfortunately no the conditions are
really really different we can mimic
just few parameters and not all the
organ or tissue environment so they are
different but even if they are different
they can still represent the originating
tissue and everything is depends on the
application that we envision for our
extracellular preparation and XSL or
vegetable based experiment so the
simples as the the simple answer is no
but we can still use XSL or vesicle
derived for cell culture as a good mimic
and it looks like we have time for one
more question our our intracellular
payload specifically incorporated into
Eevee and with which mechanisms
so apparently both membrane components
such as protein and excess LRS achill
payload such as micro rna's or generally
non-coding rnas are specifically loaded
into the vesicles and this is mainly
because vesicles do not contain all the
rnas and
all the proteins or they do not have a
method a genius representation of all
the proteins and all the RNA contents in
the secreting cells but they just in
case and represent a meaningful
selection of the proteins and the RNAs
that that we can find in the secreting
cells and specifically for example in
the work talking about liver cancer
cells micro RNA content and non-coding
RNA content we found that comparing the
microRNAs that we found enriched in the
cells and that the one that we found is
rich in the extracellular vegetables
some of them were not effective all in
the cells but only in the extra solar
particles and that for us mean that
there is a specific selection of some
micro RNAs that are directly loaded and
secreted through XSL or vegetable
mechanism
thank you Sarah do you have any final
comments for our audience
well I would like to thank everybody
thank you for attending this webinar I
hope that you you found it useful and
interesting it was a pleasure for me to
be part of this amazing project and I
would like to thank you all again
you again Sarah for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank laberd's and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through May of 2019
laboratory Lert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you